hey what is up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 6 of Minecraft of
China's adventures in Minecraft I'm
really time to hit that name so if you
guys have a better name please suggested
okay so we're back it took took me a
while to make this next episode because
I was so busy with the new arm game
programming series which which is daily
as well so I lonely I guess we make me
making this minecraft stuff when I have
time or want to feel like my microbes
which is right now so no fooling around
because we add probably the closest
closest episodes ever but like this
entire series I mean I've come close to
dying like every episode so yeah let's
let's take this seriously this is a
hardcore world um and we are we really
we really need to need to take it
seriously because this world will get
deleted if I die and we can't respawn or
anything so we need to basically put
surviving at the top of our priority
first of all when it cooks and food so
that I don't run out of food and die
second of all though I need weapons and
armor so let's get that on the road do I
I've got this I just need a lot of iron
basically I just start mining and face
the Mayan ok so I've got I've got tons
of made actually but i'll take my why
not I want to make a chest right now
the other way so I can put some my stuff
down just looking like an ounce at nice
house I guess they'll get rid of one
more layer all right um yeah okay I'll
just probably leave my chest someone
here and we'll go on our little
adventure I'll move this later but for
now chesco is here and I'm just gonna oh
right that was actually providing light
blonde you know that okay let's say
gravel cobblestone feathers all this
crap I don't need any of it really use a
stick so I guess pumpkins
what is always good just in case egg
Snarr like a cake out of them later
promise that's yeah it does look good I
need a new shovel oh well we might as
well get this one um sticks cactus nor
cacti don't need that what else anything
else useful no I think so
good to have a crafting though just in
case we get lost and yeah it's gonna be
it so we've got a lot of torches without
that many torches we've got a lot of
food though so like I died and let's get
this adventure rolling apparently a high
life is good I just will not die okay
rotten flesh as good as well like made
that um oh here we go well yeah I guess
what some money right here I mean why
not it seems to be a good place so again
putting my survival top my priorities
now what I want to talk to you guys
today about was um I guess what I should
do with minecraft because i'm at a lot
of you guys wanna i had a few ideas
actually but I I'm not sure so I think
it's pretty clear that all you guys want
to jump in and play minecraft with me so
what's gonna happen is because I sort of
want to have it all by the way to
changed my my skin to say um from you
know game style just because i had like
normal black well not not normal just to
like like a suit basically which i used
to running back on the played minecraft
like a year ago um so yeah god oppa
gangnam style gone on right now um and i
would be listening to their music but is
copyrighted so yeah not happening um but
yeah i absolutely love that song by the
way so awesome love it okay so what's
gonna happen is is there really nothing
around here well it's nighttime or idea
so we'll have a lot of is that why i
came down i remember let me just um make
sure that i can art that's not what I
came down it's not where I came down I'm
gonna like mark the exit i guess just i
don't i get lost but yeah so I was
thinking of you know running like a
server but the thing with that is I
don't really want to pay for a server
and neither do i actually want to run it
out of my house
last twenty-four seven because I'm
basically the way I operate is when I go
to sleep I turn everything off like
everything gets turned off our internet
gets turned off actually my mom sort of
um right I wouldn't mind having the
router spawn during the night but um I
sort of made a habit out of turning
everything officer my phone every news
gets shot shot off nothing stays on
every Power Point in the house is pretty
much dead obviously except the fridge
and stuff like that but um yes I'm not a
big fan of just running a server 24-7
obviously that would wipe out my power
bill which is in the mood um that I just
30 how do i get Nine sword the zombies
like drop iron swords now it's why they
use them oh also are not Tosh's a cold
I'll call sweet I'll about 55 colon 5 a
thing um so yeah that's not really an
option having a 24-7 running server the
other thing is what I really wanted to
do is just turn on the server when I'd
be playing so turn off turn on the
server when I'd be like recording a very
video stuff did you guys say that back
creeper didn't destroy anything else
gardens as fast as possible is there a
shoot arrows okay um is there a
selectable waiting to kill therapist why
did why aren't they explored like why
don't are they supposed to like destroy
this stuff ah that's actually really
weird I private-like didn't affect the
land huh that's weird um but yeah so if
you guys have any i don't know i was i
was thinking of just turning the server
on when I be playing when I be recording
videos for um for my channel
but I don't know about that if you guys
have any suggestions like I do want to
be able to host assert myself though I
don't want to jump on other people's
lives just because I want to be in
control and and yeah but I don't know if
you guys have some creative way that I
can involve you in this um then by all
means let me know if that's what I want
to do so just drop a comment and let me
know what you guys think about and if
you have any awesome suggestions as to
how I can get you guys in here I mean I
can open to LAN but that's not gonna
help you guys because you're not in my
house um so yeah I'm creating a reading
a server just for 10 minutes like only
taken the server on for like 10 minutes
a day or something that um I don't know
half my workout honestly a lot of you
guys live overseas and any different
time zones yeah sorry so yeah I found
much iron not too much I need not to
build armor go with iron armor personal
up bread so I'm not taking the 10
minutes a day or something it's gonna be
fun and obviously a lot of you guys
would like to build your own things
again the other thing is what about like
trolls and people who just don't wanted
it oh oh [ __ ] I didn't make that jump
crap oh wow I've loved you neglected to
gripe is behind me I think like kill
each other that's useful and now that it
done um yeah I don't know it seems it
seems unlike it's actually seems pretty
hard Sonic it's actually seems pretty
hard trying to get you guys on into play
with me so i don't know i don't know
maybe maybe you guys no way that I could
do that without you know what's
convenient both being you guys um let me
know i'll try to finish school though i
do want to get back to doing those
awesome fun-filled live streams oh
here's the other thing I want to ask you
guys texture pack what um what texture
pack should I write because at the
moment I'm running the development
minecraft 1 which which is cool but I
know that you guys are you guys want to
see texture packs going on so to let me
know what oops let me just divide
you know making a lot of sticks here and
we'll make a lot of torches cause we're
gonna need a lot of tortious um so yeah
texture pack let me know there's got a
dangerous something okay okay damn that
they they are dangerous [ __ ] okay guys
well I mean that's the end of this
series I hope you enjoyed it six
episodes I didn't know that was so
dangerous though like 55 hearts what is
it insanity mom ok guess I'll boys the
world hey that's it game over man ass
game over
Oh drinking some juice okay that's it I
mean that's the end of the charrids
Adventures of Minecraft I'm kind of
suitable as well so let me know probably
should have used some of that iron to
build myself mama anyway let me know
what you guys think of a new series in
terms of not really in like a new series
but of what I can do with my craft to
involve you guys because obviously I
wanna have to start doing that now I
promise that when I die um and when this
world gets deleted I will actually you
don't great like a multiplayer world or
something so let me know how I can go
about doing that there will be birth
convenient for you guys and meet and I
will see you guys I'll see you guys
later so yeah please leave please leave
a like if you enjoyed the video as well
because that's cool it's what the cool
people are doing alright guys
you